let's have some analysis now of the
Russian military operation so far and
the questions they pose for the UK and
NATO joining me now is Sir Chris devrel
former commander of the UK's Joint
Forces command
um good morning General
um you've commanded an armored Brigade
um what's your assessment of the success
or otherwise of Mr Putin's Invasion plan
to date
well good morning Trevor it's uh it's
great to be with you on this sunny
Sunday morning but I think these are
dark days for Europe foreign
I think it's a bit early to draw
conclusions about the um success or
other ways of the Russian campaign we're
actually only four days into the
conflict
I think it's possible that the Russians
have some logistic issues and it is
likely that the ukrainians are fighting
back hard but I also think that at some
point
it's likely that the Russians will take
control of Kiev though not without a
fight
do you think um the the machine seems to
have stalled do you think that just
purely to do with Ukrainian resistance
or are there other factors supply lines
and all of that kind of thing
yeah I'm sure all of that bears on on um
what's happening it's also Russian
Doctrine to develop overwhelming force
on specific axes of Advance rather than
to advance on a wide front
um if they can take control of cities
through special force attacks they will
do so but otherwise I would expect them
to avoid trying to take cities until
they have significant numbers available
because because street fighting consumes
large numbers of troops
well indeed and that would be the big
prize wasn't it cave or car cave
um
how Bloody is that likely to get
well
um I think that yeah it's hard to say
because it will in the end depend upon
how hard the ukrainians fight I think
they've given every indication they
intend to fight hard so I think it could
be very bloody I don't think it's easy
to invest a city and take a city uh
where the Defenders are determined in
their opposition without a lot of
Bloodshed and I think you know the
evidence is that
Putin's life depends upon making Ukraine
into a client state so he's all in
so at the end of the day I don't think
he's going to
restrict his use of Weaponry or or
tactics uh to achieve his name
you think that if he encounters greater
resistance that actually what he'll do
is Step Up the Firepower it's uh I think
what some people call the cornered rat
problem
um yeah I think I think
um we do have to bear in mind that
um a corner direct is very dangerous so
we need to to be thoughtful about
backing Putin into a desperate corner
but on the other hand you know I also
think that he's a playground bully
and playground bullies ultimately only
understand hard power so I think we have
to be extremely determined in our
language and our deployments as far as
NATO is concerned that we will not
tolerate any extension of this campaign
Beyond at the Ukraine and that we will
support the Ukrainian armed forces in
their fight against Russia
do you think there are more that there
is more that we could do to achieve that
and or to give them support
um
the the difficulty obviously is that if
we give them direct Military Support
then it um pretty quickly we are at war
with Russia and I do think uh that we
need to avoid that that would be a very
significant escalation of the conflict
and it's hard to see where it would end
so I think that the kinds of things that
we're doing at the moment are are right
that we need to continue them and and
increase them supplying
um weapons in particular
um to the Ukrainian Armed Forces
uh let's try spoke this morning with me
about the uh length that this conflict
might go on she's obviously
contemplating years actually
um Ukraine is a big place it's ground
area four times the size of England
um
gaining control of cities might be one
thing but holding the country is another
how
bigger set of forces would the Russians
have to commit and do you think they can
they might be able to win this conflict
but can they hold it
yeah I mean I am a bit baffled by this
point
um I I think that Putin May well have
enough troops to take control of uh
large sways of the country to to
um bring to a point the end of the
direct military confrontation but I just
can't see how he has enough troops to
maintain that control across a country
of 44 million people
um the size it is uh even with
extraordinary violent oppression which
I'm sure he would he would use
especially since
um the people are never going to forgive
him
um and lots of other countries will
likely lend support to an Insurgency so
I I must say I don't understand
how he thinks this ends well for him I
think he's made an absolutely major
miscalculation
so you think that there may be strategic
errors here I mean there is some
conversation going on about
um why does he why did he do this in the
way he has has done it do would uh you
know this is an odd way perhaps to put
it if you had been advising him would
you have
once he decided he wanted to invade
would you have advised him to do it in
the way he's done it
well um I come back to my point I made
earlier we are early days I mean if you
think about
um the uh invasion of Iraq in
um 2003 by the by the West you know
three or four days into the campaign it
looked pretty awful I have to say I was
part of that uh Invasion
um and uh it it didn't feel good from
the point of view of the attackers so I
don't think we can yet conclude that uh
this invasion is in deep trouble
um but I I do think that um I would have
been advising him not to do it in the
first place you know I I just I can't
see how the the thought of a victory
over the Ukraine Armed Forces is the
same thing as control of the country I
that's what I would have been telling
him you you'd need many many many more
troops to achieve the latter
foreign
you um were responsible for our cyber
defenses and um there this conflict may
be fought on
uh several different grounds uh uh under
the sea in cyberspace and in space
itself what other tools does he have at
his disposal and how
uh how well prepared are we to confront
them
so I think we should remember that
Russia or its proxies have been
attacking Ukraine with cyber for for
many years they uh took down for example
the Ukrainian power grid in 2015 and and
the
um famous not Petra malware attack in
2017 which was disguised as as
ransomware
um but intended to to destroy data on
affected machines had a massive impact
and and since the last in the last month
and uh increasing the last few days
there have been attacks on on Ukrainian
government websites and and on Banks and
and other government departments
so-called wiper attacks where where
um data is destroyed or denial of
service attacks where where websites are
closed down so so that is not a new
tactic for Putin and he will continue to
do it
he doesn't need necessarily to intend to
do the same to us for this to cause us
harm I mean taking the example of the
not picture Attack which I mentioned a
moment ago when that happened it was
targeted at Ukraine but it had a massive
um effect globally it leaked out of
Ukraine and
um some estimates put the total Global
cost of 10 billion dollars so so the
Cyber the use of cyber could spread
outside Ukraine uh arguably more easily
than than armed conflict
um so as to whether we are better
protected and you know what what we I
think we definitely are so the the not
picture attack in particular I think was
a wake-up call for the UK and and we now
have an excellent National cyber
security Center which is leading uh the
defense of um UK systems and we also now
have a national cyber force which is
capable of offensive action in
cyberspace
um should we be attacked so I think
we're much better off than than we were
and I do think we ought to keep the
Cyber risk in perspective as well I you
know you hear a lot of people talking
about Mass cyber attacks I don't think
that's how cyber really happens
um
it's much more likely to cause this
inconvenience and and cost than it is to
kill lots of people
in the end
um General Chris do you think that we
need to be more worried about if you
like conventional uh assault in Ukraine
and the potential for that to spread
into the Baltic states or NATO countries
or these unconventional attacks
you say cyber or maybe the cutting of
undersea cables which we've seen yeah I
mean and also you know Putin is capable
of of um attacking uh our satellites in
space
um he's capable of causing or trying to
escalate a massive Refugee crisis I mean
there are all kinds of of non-direct
military ways he could um seek to to
expand the crisis but I think it is
worth us thinking very thoughtfully
about about his ability to expand it
with direct military action I I imagine
my assumption is that he doesn't want to
direct military confrontation with NATO
but I don't think we can be certain of
that
um there is a risk that he might for
example be seeking to establish a land
bridge through either Lithuania or
Poland to the to the Russian Enclave on
the Baltic uh cliningrad
um or he could be trying to do worse
than that and I mean there is some
evidence that
um considerable amounts of the Russian
Force have not yet entered Ukraine why
not maybe for logistic reasons but maybe
also because she has purposes in mind
beyond the defeat of Ukrainian Armed
Forces so I I think it's really
important that NATO continues to shout
about its Article Five commitments and
that it it continues to
um develop its defense plans as it has
done recently with the activation of the
NATO response Force which is something
that's not happened before in history
and which many people thought would
never happen
um so so that is I think the kind of
thing we need to to be doing because we
cannot be certain that he doesn't intend
to go militarily beyond regret Ukraine I
think we can be pretty certain he
intends to have an effect Beyond Ukraine
but he might even be intending to go
militarily beyond it
General Chris so Chris several thank you
very much indeed
my pleasure thank you very much Trevor